[Music]
she may have been conscious at the time
but most likely with the
level of smoke that she had held
consciousness would have
would have decreased over time the
impact of anne heisha's fiery car crash
has left her in extreme critical
condition
now anne's rep tells e.t the actress may
not recover quote unfortunately due to
her accident ann hayche suffered a
severe and toxic brain injury and
remains in a coma in critical condition
anne's rep adds she is not expected to
survive
and has sustained life-threatening
injuries these are the most serious
injuries that we see
in burn care
e.t spoke to a burn specialist who broke
down the details of anne's accident and
what's next for her medical treatment
she has two
very significant serious
life-threatening injuries she was in an
enclosed space the car as well as an
apartment so that allowed smoke as well
as toxic gases to build up with a high
concentration which attacked her airway
and prevented her from breathing so
she's most likely in a medically induced
coma
meaning that she's on heavy sedation and
she also has severe pain
from her burn injuries
they're going to
remove the body from the vehicle and
possibly transport the victim
to a hospital
and has been treated by the staff and
nurses at grossman burn center at west
hills hospital her rep thanks the team
for their dedication and helping with
ann's recovery but now doctors are
facing some tough decisions
we're told in the event of her death and
always wanted to donate her organs
quote she is being kept on life support
to determine if any are viable
we're just praying for her recovery and
earlier this week anne's girl in the
room 13 director elizabeth rome shared
well wishes from the cast and crew
elizabeth says and gave her all to the
film set to air on lifetime in september
i know all of us at lifetime
myself larissa everybody is
devastated we are praying for her and
the victims of this
horrible tragedy and
i know that ann really really was
passionate about this film she gave it
everything that she had she brought a
phenomenal performance and force
to this project and
you know she was really committed to
stopping violence against women
anne's work ethic is something her rep
says will be a part of the actresses
lasting legacy
but more importantly she'll be
remembered for her advocacy fighting for
lgbtqia plus rights
quote more than her extraordinary talent
she saw spreading kindness and joy as
her life's work especially moving the
needle for acceptance of who you love we
want an opportunity in this world to be
able to talk about being together with
human beings so that we can engage in
their knowledge you know
and and hopefully grow as a society
because we do that
[Music]